[inaudible].
Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and ahhh just checking in on you.
How was your week going?
Is that the way you planned it is 2080 turning out to be the year you wanted it
to be?
Um,
uh,
beginning my,
my transformation of my,
my new fucking wardrobe.
But you new clothes,
uh,
you know,
something I never took seriously with socks.
I'd go down to the fucking foot locker and I just grab a pair of,
you know,
a package of those things and I would wear them for like three years.
I don't own any white socks.
They're all gray.
Um,
I dunno.
It's just something that I've never been into.
And then for Christmas,
somebody actually got me some new socks and they were great,
but they weren't like a,
you know,
like dress socks as some shit.
Like,
oh great,
I gotta wait till somebody dies against married before I wear these fucking
things.
They were just like,
you know,
they weren't athletic socks,
they would just sort of socks.
You could still wear it with sneakers.
They were a little thicker,
you know,
I'm an old man.
I was like,
keys fell real comfy on my feet.
So,
uh,
that was it.
I,
you know,
and then I had him sitting in my sock drawer next to all these sad grey socks
that had been loyal for all these years and all the old socks were looking at me
like,
Bill,
you,
you're not going to move the company to another country are you?
Man,
you're not going to break up the union.
Okay.
We been there for you for a long time,
man.
I was like,
you will get nothing.
And I owe the public nothing.
Whose quote was that?
I owe the public nothing.
It's one of those Robert Barron guys back in the day.
And who even knows if they,
if they robbed anybody,
maybe they were just better at business than most people.
Maybe they had it in him to tell some old lady they hit the brick.
She would done with them.
Let me see something who said,
was it Andrew Carnegie or Carnegie is,
they say in Pittsburgh.
Um,
I owe the public
nothing over
JP Morgan.
Oh
Ho JP JP,
the original heal.
How great,
what are you bent?
You know,
I bet if he lived right now,
he'd be,
he'd be working for Vince Mcmahon,
crushing it on the mic.
I owe the public nothing
that is so fucking mean,
so wrong.
And so right.
All at the same time.
I've never quite felt,
I'd never really felt one way or another about that one.
First I was like,
what a fucking Dick.
You know?
And then what happens is you start doing a little well in life and then all of a
sudden some douche bag in your life starts giving you shit about it and it wants
you to give them fucking money just for being there,
you know?
And you start going,
well,
I,
I guess I kind of understand what JP Morgan was saying.
Granted,
you know what I mean?
I didn't fucking create the Federal Reserve system that enslaves fucking people,
you know,
taken away from this car.
I want to get that.
I don't know.
I don't want to go down that rabbit hole.
You know?
This has always been my rule as far as helping people out.
Okay.
If you laying in a ditch and you're reaching up,
I'll reach down and try to pull you out.
All right?
But if you face down in the ditch,
digging it deeper every day.
Yeah.
I'm not throwing money in that.
Get your shit together.
Okay.
Get a little streak going.
A little street.
Go on of doing the right fucking thing that,
uh,
you'll be surprised how much the world will help you on,
I would think.
But what do I know?
I am a privileged white male.
I remember what I was born and I was on my dad's yacht,
bye.
And we were talking to the next seven presidential candidates and uh,
they were letting me decide who was going to be presidents.
It's if you're not white,
I'm sorry to let you in on this unbelievable level of privilege.
But that's basically what my childhood was like.
It was incredible.
I remember when I,
um,
when I turned 14,
I was given my first yacht.
I remember that,
you know,
and I was in a bad mood because my chauffeur was just,
I don't know if I wanted to get fucking ice cream.
And he wouldn't take me there.
And I was very upset.
MMM.
And I was like,
you work for me,
you work for me.
And he just ignored me that day.
And I was like,
I'm going to tell daddy and you're going to be fired.
And what I didn't realize was he was under instructions from my father to take
me down to the,
the,
uh,
the wharf at than sound like a good rich word.
The,
uh,
the doc that President Roosevelt gave them,
my great grandfather.
And,
uh,
they gave me my first shot and I was like,
oh,
I feel so foolish.
Um,
but my dad's still fired my show for just for upsetting me,
even though it says idea what,
we'll revisit my privileged childhood later on in this podcast.
But let's get back to,
well,
let's get back to what went down this fucking week.
Damn God damn mother fuckers,
Alabama Crimson,
Tad one yet another fucking championship.
Ugh.
God dammit.
Georgia had a bad,
I'm on the fucking ropes and then the second half came along and what happened?
Georgia goes right out there and blocks a punt.
And I don't,
I can somebody tell me how that guy was off sites.
Can somebody tell me why a bigger deal was not made other than on the mad dog
show?
They blew too brutal fucking calls when Alabama was making a great comeback,
great coaching decision by Nick Saban to put that freshman kid in a quarterback
and just stick with them.
And how about the,
uh,
the start and not being a cunt about it?
That was all great.
And then they had that running back that came in and they started using in many
ways in the second half,
Alabama did and he was just killing Georgia.
But however,
I don't,
I don't use that fucking guy was not offsite.
They blocked the punt.
You looking at at least three points on that drive.
Granted,
people can miss field goals.
God knows Alabama knows about that come the end of the game.
Then they miss the face masks call and they call it ticky tack pass interference
on third nine.
Um,
those are the games.
When you're rooting for you and your team's getting fucked you,
you literally sit there going like,
this is literally,
it's just a t,
it's a TV show.
He can't have one team just beat the shit out of the other team.
Everybody's going to turn the channel
present real.
That football game was like watching an episode of the Super Friends back in the
day,
right.
Every fucking episode was the exact same with the super friends.
Okay.
Something would happen and then all of a sudden it just looked like,
you know,
whatever.
Superman had kryptonite around his neck,
a Batman and Robin would tied together and not like they think like they cared,
but you know time that are heading towards a buzzsaw and all that type of shit
and then something would happen.
That stupid fucking monkey from the wonder twins would do something and the
second they played that song.
Yeah.
[inaudible] I remember I would get a sense of relief every time I was watching
that cartoon.
I'm like,
Oh fuck,
is this the episode Superman dies.
I mean I was young,
I didn't know any better.
And the second they would start playing that song.
I knew that they will,
they were going to make that comeback.
That's what the Alabama fucking band should've been playing when they,
when Alabama came running out in the fucking second half,
or maybe when they called off sides in that block punt.
Uh,
you got to give it up to Alabama.
Even though I'm kind of being a cunt,
bringing those things up.
But Hey,
I mean,
that did happen.
That was bullshit.
The guy didn't even fucking move.
I Dunno.
Maybe.
Maybe the referee had a better angle.
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't get how you miss a face mask when it was done to the guy carrying the
football.
I mean,
the whole fucking stadiums looking at the guy,
his head turns around.
We didn't say it.
We didn't see it.
Um,
here's what I want to know.
Who's more hateable bill Belicheck or a Nick Saban.
And secondly,
why do you hate them?
Like everyone says,
Nick Saban is the devil.
Why is he the devil?
Because he's so good at what he does.
You know?
I don't know.
I think the media fucking hates bill Belicheck cause he makes that job so
fucking
because he knows that if he opens his mouth,
the media is going to make his job more difficult by exaggerating anything that
he said given the other team.
Bolton board
material.
Um,
masterful.
The way he handles the press,
he gives them nothing.
He looks at them and he's like,
you people are not my fucking friends.
I am required by the NFL to stand here and answer your questions but I am not
required to give you anything more than two fucking syllables per question.
All right.
I love it.
I wish more coaches would do that.
More players would do that.
You know Shaq used to doing,
you ever seen Shaq like when I hour but he still went like on TBS or whatever,
t and t,
whoever does the fucking Nba,
just total
nice guy.
Affable brick area stair.
I say right number.
What he would do.
Like a,
he's talking joking around animated and all that,
but we used to do those,
those interviews at the end of the game and just be like,
well Colby or get rid of ball
[inaudible] he just went into like poker era.
You see on any other show,
it seems like a completely different guy.
That's what you learn after you get burned by those fucking nonathletic fat fuck
counts that are in the sports media.
You know,
and this is what I can't stand about them is they choose themselves,
their own self preservation over any sort of loyalty towards the home team.
You know
the local Boston sports media sitting there fanning the flames of that fucking
or shit about Tom Brady's personal assistant,
whatever.
Not Personal assistant is fucking personal trainer.
Can you fucking believe they tried that?
That's all they could get.
And then they were like,
well whatever man,
we got a spark blow on it
and what kills me is fucking patriots fans will continue to listen to those
sports shows at second.
I hear that.
I go fuck these guys.
Well Bell,
I mean,
we're at the Badaliya.
It is a story.
We have to address that.
Do you,
um,
do you just have to say what everybody else is saying?
Is that what you're required to do?
Wow.
Bill,
what happened?
You started off in such a good mood.
Um,
so Nick Saban now has,
uh,
he has six championships.
Never.
He was doing,
he has six championships.
He's 66 years old.
Six,
six,
six.
He's the devil.
Well,
Denny just turned into the devil.
What was he at when it was,
you know,
five championships and he was 65.
Well,
it's two to fives.
What does that mean?
You're going to go play that on a scratch card?
MMM.
I don't think either one of them and the devil.
I just think they're really good at what they do.
And a,
at the end of the day,
the game is 60 minutes long.
You got to keep coaching and uh,
you know what's funny?
Nowhere.
No.
In all
the top four can for sports.
All right.
Nothing hurts you more than playing.
Not to lose in football.
I've seen more goddamn games,
more fucking games.
Lost that way.
I feel like Oklahoma lost the Rosebowl because of that.
They stopped going no huddle.
You know,
if you want to be a Douche,
she could say maybe Georgia,
you know,
kind of took the foot off the gas a little bit there.
I Dunno.
Once you start thinking about how to chew up the clock,
it fucks up everybody's rhythm.
I don't know.
Or maybe I just love when Alabama loses like my favorite part of that Gabe was
fucking Nick Saban's face at halftime.
Oh.
And he had to do that fucking
what are you going to do that interview,
that stupid fucking interview.
Why they stopped those poor bastards and the most important game of that Goddamn
career and they got to sit there and talk to fucking Susie sweet shoes as they
before they go in there.
Hey,
you know why I fucking really liked on Alabama?
Was that number 14 guys a fucking maniac.
He was all over the field breaking up passes.
Anytime there was a sweet pea come out of nowhere and he was amazing.
And I also think Georgia's front forward and credible.
Like that interception that kid had.
I mean,
usually defensive Lineman,
uh,
I dunno,
they're just not quick enough
record shade off the how many found it in the air and then caught it,
um,
in that close to the quarterback.
That usually does not happen.
And uh,
yeah,
they amazing front for and George's quarterback to the freshmen obviously kinda
sucks that they ended up losing the game.
I feel it.
I actually would tell you this,
I felt bad for Nick Saban when that kid missed that field goal.
It's funny,
for some reason I didn't feel bad for the kid.
I felt bad for nick say,
but
I forget what he did.
He just threw his fucking arms up.
Like,
what do I have to do?
How big a genius too.
I have to fucking be to fuck it.
Help you sons of bitches across the God damn gold line so he can win this thing
and go,
go home.
What more do I have to do?
I would love to interview coaches and be like,
what goes through your fucking brain?
All right.
Like an offensive coordinator,
whatever you call all the right place.
You play in fucking
high stakes chess,
where you literally,
your house,
your family standard of living is on the line because if you suck,
you're going to get fired.
And then that way you're gonna go,
you're gonna have to fucking sell your house.
You Ain't know that deal pill.
We know that deal.
And you call all the right place.
60 minutes of play in chess on television where every fucking Douche in the
world like myself is going to second guess you who has never even coached the
game at a pop Warner level.
You get all the way down there.
It's a fucking chip shot.
Yeah.
And this soccer style con goes in there and fucking Mrs said like,
just like how do you sleep that night?
I,
I can't,
I can't imagine.
You know what I mean?
Everybody talks about the field goal kickers when they miss it and what they
have to deal with.
You know,
it's,
it's very simple.
Okay.
Nobody knows what a field goal kicker looks like.
You move out of this state,
you start selling cars,
you begin a new life,
egg,
noodles and ketchup somewhere,
right?
Yeah.
I can't imagine the coach.
So you got it.
Like how do you go to sleep at night?
You know,
and you know,
your wife doesn't understand.
College is just a game.
Come back to bed.
I don't understand what is wrong with you.
You're scaring the children,
Michael.
Okay
guys.
Just I would say,
you know what I would do?
I would just be standing up in my living room drinking with my headset still on
staring at the fucking wall.
Okay.
Kids,
we're going to go to bed early tonight.
Your father's had a tough day.
I Dunno.
That's what I see when I,
when Nick Saban's losing,
when I look at that guy's fucking face,
it's just like,
I would not,
it's just not a guy you'd want.
You would want to piss off.
Um,
I love those guys that are going bald and they still dye their hair and they
still keep it like long.
Like,
I don't know.
What is Nick Saban doing?
So he's got cotton candy on top of his head.
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead.
By the way,
Nhl fans,
did you happen to catch?
Did you happen to see the fucking best gay by the year?
At least the ones that I saw.
Do you watch the Bruins first of penguins?
That game?
It was like a game from the 80s,
except there was no fights,
which there should have been when the puck somehow got lost in a shower,
his Jersey and that guy came up and just sort of looked at him and then pushed
him down like a kid on the playground.
And I was like,
all right,
somebody's got to drop the gloves there.
Even though what he did was totally legal.
That doesn't make a difference.
This is hockey.
Can't just have him push your captain down like that.
Um,
then nobody did shit cause that's the new game because they're trying to get
everybody to fucking watch,
which they're not going to do.
Fighting is basically out of hockey and all of these fucking,
uh,
Olympic ice hockey watching cons are still not watching.
They're not,
they're not gonna Watch it.
All right?
Basketball.
They'll keep watching that fucking players going into the standards,
accidentally punched it.
A woman trying to get to some guy in a track suit that through a fucking
cocacola on your face,
right?
People keep watching.
They don't give a shit,
right?
Players fucking getting busted for shit and bring it up.
Other players names,
nobody gives a fuck.
They keep fucking watch it and then they say,
Oh,
you got to get the fighting out of hockey.
Really?
Oh,
tell you what?
Why don't you get the fighting out of boxing first and then I'll actually
believe that you're against violence.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
Bruins verse penguins.
This is how the scoring went.
One,
nothing Bruins.
Then it was one one than two.
One pens,
then three one pence.
Right now my GAF.
Fuck.
Here we go.
We just,
we keep,
we can,
what are we doing here?
Right then in the fucking second period it became,
it was three to two penguins,
three to three,
four to three Bruins,
five to three broads.
Okay,
so we scored the first goal,
penguin scored the next three.
Then we scored the next four,
and this isn't even the end of the fucking second period yet.
All right.
Eight fucking goals.
This is back when like Gretzky would scoring a goal,
a game.
I felt like I was watching this,
this game on the fucking USA network was amazing.
Um,
and then right before the period ends,
you know,
I was thinking like,
don't let,
don't give up a goal to give them hope.
Don't fucking do that shit.
And what do they do?
They fucking give up a goddamn goal
and it ends up being five to four at the end of the second period.
Nine fucking goals,
right?
Third period starts at like,
we got to get the next one.
We've got to get the next one.
Penguin score the fucking next one.
Now it's five to five.
And it was just play off love,
play off,
play off level hockey,
the tire rest of the fucking game.
Unbelievable passes.
Unbelievable.
I can't believe I'll fucking fast.
Abroads uh,
um,
got all these young kids out there.
It's amazing.
And ended the game.
Brad Marshawn comes down on sort of like a mini breakaway.
Sky's slashes him on his right hand,
right.
And it goes down and a,
the ref calls a fucking penalty shot.
What I loved is even after he called the penalty shot,
my show was still shaking his hand to make sure you know the ref.
You see,
look at east slash me this hand,
this hand,
right.
And uh,
am I going to,
Sean's going to score this fucking goal.
He's going to fucking score this goal.
It comes down and gets a pet fucking head of steam a little this way,
a little that way.
Fucking five hole opens up.
He goes to Tuck it in and that fucking penguins can.
Jess got the top of his pad on it to block it.
We go into overtime and um,
unbelievable.
Three on three hockey and then fucking wasn't market.
Plus he the one who scored.
I mean penguins are tough and all the time,
you know,
they got Crosby on one line pant Malkin and another three on three.
All that open ice and Phil Kessel,
former Bruin farmer Brewen that we traded to Toronto because of that trade.
We want a cup.
So I don't want to fucking hear about it.
Um,
incredible game.
Unfortunately you didn't win,
but,
uh,
the Bruins are very excited to watch this year as exciting as the Celtics.
Dare I say,
dare I say,
um,
have no advertising today.
Everybody,
people are slowly walking away from my podcast.
Evidentaly
you know what I say?
I say that's their loss.
Uh,
admitting when you guys listen to other fucking podcast and they just do a
straight read,
you fucking,
you blow through it.
You blow through these assholes did not understand what I was doing.
I was misunderstood.
Would you like that guy?
Tucker used to make those cars except I was the advertising illiterate version
of it.
Right.
You know what's annoying as I tried to print something out before I started
doing this podcast and my printer's out of paper.
So the stupid fucking printer icon keeps jumping up and down.
You know,
like when you have a big family and there's that one kid,
you don't really like any kind of senses it,
so he tries to do extra shit to get attention.
That's what he's doing right now.
MMM.
Anyways,
I'm going to be at a cobb's comedy club this Saturday night with Rosebowl
tailgate legend,
10 year vet
Joe,
nick,
10 years Tommy.
So it should say,
sorry,
10 games in a row at the rose bowl.
Do you know we were there and the,
when they introduced it,
we thought we were bad ass.
What that 10 10 games in a row and they,
oh this fucking print or jumping up and down.
I get it.
MMM.
Somebody was at the game and he was at his 70th Rosebowl in a row.
Sky's been going since 1948 no,
cause I was already thinking like the,
the,
the guys that we had seen.
Okay.
Like the,
that have then gone,
it'll either gone pro or one like the Heisman trophy or something like justice.
And the first like,
uh,
I don't know how many years
that kid on the titans who went to Stanford,
that white kid who's really fast,
who scored that touchdown last week,
whatever his name is,
McCaffrey or some shit.
We saw him saw Mark Sanchez Sanchez the first year.
Jamison Winston.
What's that?
Mary Yoda,
Kit Macgyver for whatever his name is for the titans,
up too old to remember the fucking names.
And then we saw that tech kid on Penn state,
the running back,
Shane courses,
whatever his name is.
We saw him last year
and this year we saw a Brewster baker in the six pack or whatever that fucking
name is,
who's Bruceton Bank or how come on old people who remember cable when it first
came out back when these entertainment industry was so amazing.
They let Kenny Rogers started movies.
Do you realize Kenny Rogers has all kinds of hit records?
He started a fucking movie and uh,
had fast food chicken restaurant.
I don't know if he still has all that,
but they had to have been a point.
You know,
at some point you had to looked at whoever was his manager of just be like,
dude,
I'm kind of spreading and spreading it a little thin.
I'd have,
fuck,
can you keep putting out hit records and make sure you know,
nobody's putting their hands in the register at your 40 fucking Kenny Rogers
chicken places.
How much do you love Kenny Rogers?
That you like,
you know what,
I bet he makes good chicken too.
Like how much do you believe in him as an artist?
And you're like,
well cookings and art form too.
So you know,
I mean I love led Zeppelin,
but if John bought him,
started making fucking meat pies,
I mean I,
I think I'm going to pass,
I don't remember that being part of his fantasy during the song remains the
same.
Watching him,
making some sort of fucking,
you know,
fry up are a fucking fish and chips.
It was that he was out on a and in a drag race,
so that,
that makes sense.
Um,
he's such a horribly misunderstood musician.
Such a horribly misunderstood by myself.
Also,
you know,
I was talking to somebody the other day,
there's always been like this,
this myth about bond him that he used to play with these sticks that lonely like
tree trunks.
And I remember like trying to get his sound and I went out and I bought like a
pair of like two bs or something like that.
So if you don't know what those are,
I mean this thing is so big around that like,
you know,
80 years ago illegally,
you probably couldn't beat your wife with it.
I mean that's,
that's how big this fucking piece of wood was.
Right?
Thinking that you are going to get that sound.
And uh,
is it a couple of fucking pictures that I've looked up though.
If you really look,
it looks like he's just using like almost like a five a or five B.
Just a regular sized stick.
It's just he just knew any,
if you really look at him play,
he's like,
he never really brings his hands up and slams down on the drums.
He's kind of wrist and fingers.
He just knew how to fucking hit the drum.
I'll tell you another guy who was amazing.
I was talking to my drum teacher about this as I watched this clip of a James
Gadson who uh,
played with that,
that watts hundred third street band where the,
you know the one
express di Di di Di di Di [inaudible] people over that fucking song was bill
withers basically took that rhythm section
and he went out on the road,
made albums with them and there's a live version of him,
uh,
James Gadson playing and he's playing like 16th notes and he's doing a little
ghost notes on the snare and whenever you would go to hit the backbeat I don't,
it didn't even look like he came like two inches up off the drum.
It's like his ghost notes would down about a half an inch and then he would just
go
mean mathematically that works out cause he's like four times higher.
It should sound,
but how the crack he was getting off the snare drum is incredible.
Um,
anyways,
I have no idea what I'm,
do you know,
I'm trying to do,
I'm just trying to fill up fucking 30 minutes talking about the intricacies of
different fucking drummers.
40 50 years ago.
Um,
yeah,
so that's it.
Billy new wardrobe.
All right.
And,
uh,
I got all these fucking clothes that fit me,
even if I'm a fat fuck,
uh,
opiate booze bag.
So when I'm doing is I am a,
I'm given all of that away and I'm not taking it over to the fucking,
um,
what do you call it?
Goodwill.
I don't believe in those guys.
You'd go over there and people do anything that they don't want.
They just drop off over there.
So they only have the guilt,
you know,
it's like,
let's let these people throw it in the fucking ocean.
Right?
Actually have a friend of mine that actually is,
uh,
works for this place.
You know,
people recovering addicts and all of that type of shit.
What I'm saying is this going to be some really well dressed x junkies out
there?
Not to say that I have the greatest taste.
I'm just say that the,
you know,
the homeless people in my neighborhood and we'll be looking at all right.
Um,
what do you do with socks?
So,
even if you wash them,
I can't get my gray socks to people.
You know what I mean?
Underwear.
You definitely have to fucking throw out.
That goes without saying,
even though I just said it.
Um,
but uh,
I am in very happy with the shape I'm in right now and I'm going to just,
I'm going to buy clothes that just fit this fucking shape.
That's it.
So if I start getting out of shape,
all of a sudden my share,
it'll start creeping up.
My fucking white belly will be hanging out.
I'm just going to have to take it
because I'm not buying bigger clothes.
That's what I'm going to do,
you know,
it's all about not becoming a fat fuck,
you know?
And I finally turned the corner with my shoulder.
I didn't have to do any Coby Bryant,
fucking Peyton manning blood in the centrifuge and fucking Transylvania.
And I got blessed those two guys for doing that too,
because now like you can get that everybody's getting it done,
you know what I mean?
And uh,
you know,
pretty soon they'll level at stem cell research and all that shit.
I'm just waiting like,
uh,
I'm still too afraid to get lasik eye surgery.
I'm not going to do the stem cell shit.
What's his face?
Rogan was trying to hook me up with that.
I just,
I that's too,
I get a little nervous about that.
You know,
what does that,
they take up placenta out and they put it in one of those kitchen aid things and
then then,
uh,
dropped a little virgin blood in there.
It just seemed a little too fucking crazy to me.
Like,
and then you just get this brand new shoulder and it's like,
and then that's just it.
There's no price to pay.
I don't have like a slight fucking tick in my personality.
You know,
like those fucking movies,
we get like a hand transplant and they took it off the cadaver or someone who
was a mass murderer and all of a sudden the hand wants to keep murdering.
You know,
you get your shoulder fixing.
All of a sudden you check your grandmother.
Yeah.
Boarding,
you know,
she's bent down in a house coat to pick up a slipper.
You just send her into the fireplace you like,
man,
I don't know why it did that.
It's not being mad.
It's my no shoulder.
Like,
you know,
whatever.
I'm a fucking idiot.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Enjoy the music and now we're going to give you a little half hour of 'em.
Some a classic Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast from the Thursday gone by in a year that already happened
or possibly earlier this year.
Congratulations Alabama.
Uh,
you guys are the fucking Yankees.
You're the fucking Celtic shear.
The Montreal Canadian.
Yeah.
Via the Green Bay packers of the,
of,
of college football.
You can't debate it.
You guys are the best.
All right.
Congratulations.
You fucking cunts.
All right,
that's it.
I'll,
uh,
I'll have to have a great weekend.
Your counselor talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible]
you
were smelly.
Luvo was she loud to get sent
out
to
[inaudible] what's
going on?
It's built burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 11th,
2010.
You know,
I was going to try to start this podcast just by saying hello,
but now it's like such like a a uh,
it's a tick.
It's like I have to say it,
I got to say,
Hey,
what's going on again?
She'd be like,
hello,
this is bill Burke.
You know,
I can't switch it up.
That's my catch phrase.
What's going on?
Um,
you know,
I figured out what this cough is.
Did I tell you about it?
I'm coughing up what tastes like lighter fluid and it's actually the,
the chemical that they put on the outside of those,
those kinks first or whatever the fuck they are.
Those bricks have been grilling a lot and every,
you know,
when you grill on a Hibachi,
I dunno what it is.
Um,
somehow no matter you stand,
it's always blown in your face.
So,
uh,
anyway,
so let's get down to business here this week.
I won't be whispering this week because,
uh,
you know,
if that was just like a one day vigil for,
for old people,
you know,
I flew the flag at half mast and a,
I also was doing that doing the podcast,
by the way.
I was doing it last last week.
I did it Sunday night at 11 o'clock at night.
So are you fucking morons who sent me emails going to bleed?
We spoodle you wrote a book.
The book is,
I mean,
didn't you see the comedy in that,
that a 41 year old guy was whispering?
You got to take everything at face fucking value.
Like I was gonna Whisper for the rest of my podcast.
You're dumb fucks like five emails about that,
you know?
And it's not even like I don't like these people.
It just reminds me of how fucking stupid I am and you know,
as a human being,
if this is what I attract and believe me,
I got a lot of shit this week.
The Jesus freaks came out and force this week.
Um,
I'll be reading those later and uh,
I have some questions for you people.
Okay.
So all right.
Um,
evidently is come to my attention that g cast,
which is the server,
is that the correct computer word?
Um,
why is the same as 46 degrees out here?
It's not 46 degrees.
Just sat on my fucking Hoodie was dying out there anyways.
It's kind of my attention that a g cast,
the server that I post all my podcasts on is not going to be accepting any new
podcasters or any new podcasts as of February 1st.
So what that means is,
I'm sad to say that the Monday morning podcast is coming to a close.
All right?
It's a,
you know,
everything has a beginning,
everything has a middle and everything has an end.
So say it be shared should say it'd be done.
All right,
so I'm riding this fucker out till January 31st and then that is it.
No more.
And Nada,
you guys are on your own on Mondays.
Okay.
Cause I'm not playing this fucking Internet game anymore.
You know,
I already went from fucking my space over to Facebook and now I've got to go to
g cast to fucking age cast.
Fuck all of them.
All right.
You want to hear my jokes?
You come out and you see me,
you put money in my pocket,
then I'll dance for you.
I'm just fucking with you.
I need some help on that.
I just said that cause you know you're like someone who's not going to kill
themselves but they just say they're going to so they can just find out how much
people care.
No,
no true though.
We love you.
You have so much to live for.
You have a Monte Carlo,
you have for Laura seats,
you're going to get the air conditioning six.
And even if you don't,
you still have the tee.
Um,
no I'm not gonna I'm not going to quit.
What?
Just cause g cast is tapping out,
you know,
and you know why they're tapping out is because of guys like me.
You know what I mean?
It's this whole fucking free entertainment thing.
I don't try to charge for the podcast.
They don't charge me for uploaded.
Nobody's making any fucking money.
We're just,
we're,
we're dancing for free and we're getting sweaty and our shiny shirts a stick
into our chest and we're starting to go,
what the fuck are we doing here?
We want to get paid.
So I think that that's what's going on.
Um,
I dunno,
I consider the podcast more of a hobby,
but I got to tell you,
um,
when I get into my fifties,
in eight or nine years here,
believe it or not,
Jesus as,
um,
yeah,
there's gonna come a moment where I'm not going to be wanting to go on the road
and uh,
at that point I'll have to start charging for the podcasts and I really
shouldn't have in my fifties,
because I might start doing it when I turned 42.
You know,
whatever.
You guys can't get mad at me.
I'm trying to live the dream wouldn't be awesome if you could just fucking lay
around all day,
you know,
Talk Shit and dual microphone.
Right.
You know?
What the hell that accent come from,
right?
You talk shit new microphone gray.
Just think about this dream.
Okay?
You fucking sit around all day.
You Talk Shit,
you're rubbing your bulls.
So you have the JJ is,
Oprah says,
don't you hate it?
Which fucking older women talk about their fucking privates.
You know,
it's just,
it's fucking old.
People shouldn't do that.
You don't have that.
She's old,
but she's old enough to know.
Just like Madonna,
you know,
put your clam away.
Okay.
You're going to give people,
you begin went down on Madonna at this point you'd get like food poisoning.
I'm sorry.
It was disgusting.
You know?
Fuck.
Speaking of that,
and it'll be in Seattle.
Speaking of fish,
I'm going to be just thought of fisherman's wharf.
I'm going to be up in Seattle this week at uh,
doing uh,
Marty reamers,
uh,
funny fest at the paramount theater.
Uh,
all the information is
up@billbird.com.
B U R r.com.
You go there,
you click on the link,
you buy tickets,
you come out,
I talk,
I tell my jokes.
You Go,
wow,
that was really funny.
And then you go home to your life and I go back to the hotel and I stare at the
ceiling.
Um,
all right,
let's stay on course here.
Um,
yeah,
so I need to know what the next g cast is.
All right.
You guys gradually helped me go from my space onto Facebook and a,
which I'm doing,
which sucks,
by the way.
Thanks a lot for the advice.
You know,
Facebook sucks.
All these fucking people can find you out of nowhere and they start talking to
you.
Then I also found out that I can only add 5,000 people.
I got to start my own page.
There's already a fan page.
Now I've got to figure out how to take the fucking thing over.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't know.
It's,
it's uh,
you know,
it's fucking weird.
Then all of a sudden somebody kicked in the balls and third grade find you.
It's just weird.
It's just a weird,
I don't know.
I don't fucking,
My space was better.
My space is better.
I could just say this is me and I could start my own page.
I didn't have to fucking say,
oh,
this is just a fan page and pretend like it's not me,
but it really is me.
You know,
there was a truth in my space that I liked.
This is me whoring myself out.
How are you as opposed to now?
Gee,
Bill,
why don't you explain it 15 different fucking ways.
We've been on Facebook for three years.
You'd think we don't know what it is.
Um,
so anyways,
if you guys know what the new,
uh,
the new g cast is going to be,
if you could help me out.
Um,
I'm also going to call up other comedians,
um,
such as Mark Marin.
All right.
Mark Marin,
who does,
uh,
the WTF as in what the fuck podcast every weekend.
I actually was on his show last week and had an,
I had a great time,
just had a great time.
And uh,
these podcasts are fucking unbelievable.
I'm really like a,
a huge fan of these and how like a bunch of comedians are doing them now and
then you get like different Comedians,
uh,
can go on together and shoot the shit.
I think it's a,
it's tremendous.
I wish they had these back in the day when I was coming up and I was listening
to my favorite comedians.
You know,
I would love to hear them shoot the shit with each other,
but you know,
they didn't have computers back then.
We'll they did.
They had those ones that were the size of a fucking elementary school,
you know,
and they had those big reel to reel tapes.
Remember that?
I used to love how like on like the $6 million man,
they just had all those fake computers in the background was just like Christmas
tree lights that were just blinking on and off.
Then there was always like,
like the big,
yeah,
the big reel to reel three quarter inch tape.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm going to be on that as of today.
Um,
I got to find God dammit.
I gotta look that up.
I think it's,
what the fuck.
I hope Marin doesn't listen to this cause I told him I was going to hype it and
then I did.
And let me look it up.
What?
WTF podcast typing with my middle finger.
There we go.
Mark Marin podcasts yet WTF pod dot L I B s y n.com.
Go on that and you'll listen to me talking to,
you know,
I actually covered some of the material,
not material,
just sort of riffing from last week.
I did tell him the story of the old man yelling at me.
And uh,
for those of you who are going to be like,
cool,
you already,
you already said you repeated,
repeated a couple of things do you said?
Yeah.
Kind of like you do when something happens to you,
when you retell the story becomes a story and you tell it.
Listen to that here,
that lighter fluid sound like fucking Lucille Ball.
Do you remember how,
how fucking old I was talking with the fuck was I talking to this about,
about how quickly people got old back in the day.
Like celebrities,
like Lucille ball is unbelief.
She looks,
you know,
she looks gorgeous on I love Lucy,
I love Lucy,
um,
faces all smooth or whatever.
And then,
I don't know,
her next show was in color that show with Mr. Mooney and she just comes out and
she's,
let's say add this I that,
that fucking camel unfiltered cigarettes.
I think that's cause yeah,
back then they smoke kind of unfiltered cigarettes.
And I'm being Tan was really big for a celebrity and she was a redhead.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know what happened.
So anyways,
is that,
that that is where I'm at.
I need some help here as far as,
um,
where I'm going,
where I'm going to post these,
uh,
these latest podcasts and a,
and that's it.
Now we're into the podcast.
I just bullshitted for 10 minutes.
All right.
Um,
last week I talked about the old guy downstairs and how I was having a problem
with him and I,
I gotta tell you,
I was really surprised at the feedback that I got from that.
Um,
some of your suggestions,
I know a lot of you were joking,
but nobody really gave me any good advice that I really saw other than,
you know,
he's all just fucking let them be and whatever people go to do,
you know what I would do?
I fucking turned my TV up as loud as they fucking Kludge Jode I'd put this Gel.
I buy a fucking Tuba,
right?
I buy a toolbox.
I had hired new fucking porches in a second.
He came out,
I just fucking blow into it and the guy would think,
did he shit his pants right.
You just keep fucking doing it till he really does does shit and his paying what
idiots.
I love that whole,
you know,
I would be loud as humanly possible.
Whatso I can actually piss off the same neighbors in my complex who are actually
paying a decent amount of rent.
When they start complaining then I'm in fucking trouble.
Okay,
I'll let fucking,
uh,
you know,
this one guy was just like,
I think,
Oh God,
I got to find this fucking email.
This guy tried to suggest that because the guy downstairs use the term hip that
he was actually a racist
because any used the definition of hip from way back in the day and zoot suits
and I didn't even know what the fuck he was talking about.
Yeah.
I was just like,
you're projecting this on him.
It's like,
okay,
so you can project what you want to project on them.
I Dunno.
Why am I taking this shit seriously?
Alright,
let's move on here.
You guys were here.
So here's a couple of youtube videos you want to check out.
This one is,
this one is actually not a youtube video.
Um,
this is just a great one about this kid who had a party down in that could got
completely out of control and now his parents are being sued for 20 grand.
He sort of the Australian Jeff Spicoli and they put them on the news and the uh,
the news lady keeps trying to get them to apologize and he doesn't really give a
shit.
It's fucking great.
Um,
and this is what it is.
Get you a little pens and pencils out.
All right,
grab your post.
Its,
it's on break.com and uh,
the name of the video is funny kid isn't sorry about huge party break.com B r e
a k.com.
And um,
I don't know,
I really want to tell you what happens but then I'll ruin it.
And it's,
um,
actually,
you know,
something that made me feel better about America when I saw that because it
looked that looked like an American story and the newscaster look,
you know,
it's just nice to see that those stories about nothing that don't even matter
exist in other countries.
And if you,
if you are in another country and uh,
you have some shit like that because people always trash in America about how
fat and fucking stupid we are.
And I'll,
you know,
we're just being fed bullshit.
This is a classic,
classic kind of store that you see on the news here in the states as they call
them.
So it's just great to see that down under,
you know,
by the way,
speaking of Australia,
what is the deal?
What's the deal with that?
Foster's lager with that depth charge size beer can,
that's why I've never drank one.
I never understood like the 40 ounce either.
It's like,
let me hold this in my hand until it gets pissed,
warm.
You know?
Why wouldn't you just,
Oh,
you get those big Oktoberfest beer steins and they pour like 19 beers in there.
It's like,
why don't you just have a beer,
finish it and then move on to the next one.
It can be nice and cold and you see that little frosty smoke coming out the top.
Oh my God,
I'm getting fucking thirsty
by the way.
I'm 10 days into my sobriety.
And um,
I gotta say I,
uh,
I miss it.
I really miss it and I don't crave it.
I like it.
Did I already talk about this last week?
I can't even fucking remember.
And,
uh,
if I told you guys what I did this week,
I went to that guitar center drum off friend of mine hooked me up with some
tickets and,
um,
I saw these fucking unbelievably talented drummers.
I got to be backstage and it was just like every fucking famous drummer you
could.
Kenny Aronoff,
Tommy Lee,
Allen White,
uh,
Taylor Hawkins,
who fuck else was there.
Uh,
Danny Carry,
Chad Smith was fucking everybody.
Jason bottom,
everybody was,
it was fucking unreal.
I want to get pictures with all of them,
but I didn't,
I was just like,
cause I could tell they were all fucking,
you know,
cause they're all on the road all the time.
They never get to see each other.
Now they're all just hanging there talking drums.
And I didn't want to be like,
you know,
like that fat guy in animal house.
Like,
hey you guys playing cards.
I didn't want to do it.
So I just,
you know,
I was just like,
all right,
just remember everything that's here and this is what sucks is I was on the
wagon and I have done a shot of Yeager was somebody's fucking super famous and I
fucking turned it down just because I was on the fucking wagon.
So I don't know if that means I'm smart or I'm fucking stupid.
But at the bottom line it was,
it was Diego,
which I've never understood.
It's like,
it's like motor oil and syrup and you know something that,
that does become an age we,
you don't drink Yeager anymore.
Do you want to do a Yeager bump?
No,
I don't.
I'll drink some fucking drink,
some vodka,
maybe a little scotch.
And I'll pretend like I'm a fucking man,
you know?
And I'm shaving designs into my chest hair.
Um,
all right.
So anyways,
uh,
yeah,
I gotta admit I fucking miss it and there is no god damn way I'm going to make
it until March.
I know I'm not,
but I'm just taking it a,
you know,
yeah.
I'm not an alcoholic.
I just really enjoy it.
You know,
this is this like for me,
quitting alcohol forever is the same as just being like a,
just saying like,
I'm never going to have ice cream again.
It's like,
why?
Why wouldn't you,
why ice cream is awesome.
You know,
you don't have it every day and you've,
so you've become a fat fuck.
I'm not saying to do that,
but to never have it again.
You know,
to never have a,
you know,
a beer or a glass of wine,
I don't know.
There's no fucking way I'm making it.
This is really making me thirsty.
And you know what else sucks is I got all these great beer glasses,
like those glasses they have on the commercials,
you know,
even got those Sam Adam ones for Christmas.
And uh,
I've just been filling them up with water drinking.
It's fucking sacrilegious,
dude.
I don't know if this cop's going to go away.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
oh yeah,
somebody wrote me who was at the rose bowl,
evidently cheap trick was playing there and they,
she was giving me shit for drinking,
which she should have.
And she goes,
I feel bad for you.
And one of the reasons why she goes is you,
you missed the greatest band in the world.
Cheap trick.
And uh,
you know,
come on,
really at this point,
cheap trick is still the greatest band ever.
Do you really want to see people who are pushing 60 singing?
I want you to want me.
That really goes back to Oprah.
Say and VJ Jay or Madonna walking around with one of her pussy lips hanging out.
It's like,
you know,
at some point you got to put your genitals away and just realize it's over.
Okay.
Yeah,
I dunno,
but what are you supposed to do?
You've got to make money.
You've got to sing the hits,
right.
That's okay.
What is lady Gaga going to sing about?
And she really gonna walk around with no fucking pants that I just bring up lady
Gaga.
I look at me,
look at me bringing up the new shit music.
Um,
is it me or is this like the worst music of all time with that auto tune?
I don't even give a shit about that of topic.
I'm just a fucking scrolling around here.
Okay.
Another youtube thing.
I actually,
somebody sent me this great link that I,
of course I lost.
There's been a couple of people who um,
have been taking clips from my podcast and adding pictures to them.
Um,
I guess if you just search my name,
somebody did one where I was talking to,
somebody asked me the question,
if you were in a gymnasium full of eight year olds,
how many of them do you think you could kill before they overpowered you?
And,
uh,
somebody put pictures to the answer to my story and I actually really enjoyed it
because,
uh,
I kind of forgot that question.
You know,
it's been long enough where I actually got to listen to it like it was somebody
else and they did a great job with it.
So whoever it did that or is doing those,
I really appreciate that because they're fucking funny.
They're really cool looking and maybe I'll sell a couple extra tickets at the
uncle fucky Shit Shack,
whatever the hell on performing.
Um,
so thank you for whoever the hell is doing those.
all right.
That's it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Next topic since really fucking is just really just I need to booze again
tonight,
you know,
to make it flow more.
Um,
somebody asked me this question or actually told me a story of a friend of his,
this is sort of a reoccurring story that I've heard over the years.
Okay.
Uh,
do it.
A friend of mine was hanging out and this famous athlete was there and uh,
they had a couple of drinks and next thing you know,
it's like the guys kind of hitting on him,
you know,
what the fuck,
blah,
blah.
So this guy was telling this story about this professional athlete,
I guess,
who,
uh,
allegedly was hitting on a friend of his.
And in the end he's like,
dude,
you know,
I don't,
I don't really,
uh,
you know,
it doesn't bother me anyways,
but he said,
so what do you think,
what do you think about gay people in Pro Sports?
I mean,
the amount of people who play in the various pro sports,
there has to be more than a couple.
Um,
what do you think about it?
I think it's fucking hilarious and I hope somebody comes out at some point
because it,
and I hope it's a football player because it's such a,
you know,
they're always fucking thumping their chest and shit and screaming.
And it would just be funny,
especially if it was somebody really dominant.
You know what I mean?
Like just some psycho middle linebacker who's just fucking a drill at night.
And that's a bad word,
who's just fucking stick and everything about it is gay drilling,
sticking,
you know,
football is a really gay sport.
When you look at it,
you know,
this is really hacky material,
but you know,
you don't like me.
What if it was the quarterback?
And then the center's got a bend over in front of me that the whole fucking
thing,
just the uncomfortableness alone in the locker room.
And then what's even better is,
you know,
those people who show up at sports bars and they have the name of their favorite
player on the back,
which I always thought was hilarious because it's always this sort of an element
of like,
and I always reminded me of,
uh,
of high school,
like when the cheerleader would be dating the quarterback Keats sheet,
where is Letterman jacket?
Jesus Christ built.
What'd you go to high school in the fifties you know what I mean?
She'd fucking wear his jacket.
So I always thought it was a,
I was with some buddies yesterday in the sports bar and they were talking about
that,
that the only Jersey you can wear as like the Jersey of a guy who was like,
who is this shit when you were a kid?
Cause then then it was okay to wear like a Roger Staubach Back Jersey or
something.
But when you're an adult and you're wearing the Jersey of a guy who's like just,
it's,
it's Kinda Gay,
the whole fucking thing is kind of gay.
So when it makes sense,
you know,
they always patting each other on the,
I think it would be fucking hilarious.
But the problem is,
is I don't think a lot of other people with that,
that's like one of the certain times there's certain stories that come out and I
just kind of stay off the Internet for like four days because I just don't want
to see the fucking,
the hate in all the,
the shit that,
you know,
it would start with that and then it would eventually go over to TV and then
they would get caught up in the air.
Quote,
hysteria.
Um,
and then the Bible people would come out and they would start talking about the
Lord says that it's a man should never lay with another man and all that fucking
shit.
And,
um,
then they would say role models that the classic hysteria over absolutely
nothing that like literally 8% of the population would be freaking out about.
And the other 92% would he be watching and just,
or would just completely not even give a shit.
So,
uh,
I don't know if that's what I feel.
I don't think,
I don't think it's,
look,
if you can fucking catch the ball and make my tape when,
uh,
I don't give a fuck,
I'll take a whole team of fags
to not have what happened to my team yesterday against the fucking ravens.
I don't give a shit.
They can all skip onto the field.
I could give a fuck just when the Goddamn game.
Um,
wow.
Hats off to the fucking ravens.
That's fucking a,
that was total domination.
And I gotta tell you,
I'm really disappointed in patriots fans with the amount of fans that fucking
left.
But I got to tell you,
I'm not surprised.
I'm really not surprised because that is a through line through all the fucking
sports,
the amount of people who show up when you're winning,
everybody shows up when they're
good morning,
you know,
and then all of a sudden you go through some rough waters.
Right.
And then where does everybody go?
They all fucking leave.
Oh,
I'm not watch new shirt and everybody fucking storms out.
Eh,
that that was,
that was embarrassing.
He stayed at the end.
I stayed at the end of the sports bar taking shit from people I'll do,
speaking of which,
I went to this sports bar and this fucking ravens fan.
It was almost like performance art.
Like you know,
like when you go to a sports bar,
the one thing that sucks is going to be the people who are rooting for the other
team.
You know,
people are going to break balls like as a patriots fan,
you know,
you go in there,
if you're going to wear any sort of patriots,
you know,
tee shirt or a hat,
somebody is going to be like a you fucking cheaters or uh,
you know,
fuck the Patriots and you know what I,
whatever the fuck they gonna say,
um,
you know,
break time,
breathe Brady's other knee,
the usual bullshit.
But then there's always those people who take it too far and it starts to get to
the point of,
uh,
you know,
there's going to be a fight.
All right,
this guy,
I've never seen anything like this gate when the Ravens,
the Ravens scored a touchdown on their first play,
literally handed the ball off and ray rice just runs right up the gut and then
breaks it to the left and just goes right.
Okay.
And as they're doing it right.
This guy who everyone was saying look like it was like Kevin James Sort of build
with the head of Shrek and I'm not even joking and he just starts going like,
is the guys when he scored the touchdown,
this guy did like this.
I can't even just,
I can't,
I wish I was doing a video podcast and no,
I'm not going to start doing those.
Um,
he just started going,
he started doing like if just met,
if you exaggerated like walking,
like if he just were bringing your knees up really high and you will like
bringing your fucking arms up almost like you are power walking,
but you're doing it in slow motion and he just was gone.
Ah,
like as long as you could do it until you out of breath.
And then the funniest thing ever was winning at the end of it.
He yelled out super bowl.
I almost fucking fell down into my breakfast burrito when he yelled at Super
Bowl.
It's fucking a wildcard game.
You just went up seven and nothing on the first play in this guy.
He's,
he's calling Superbowl already and dude,
I'm telling you,
and this was the thing when he was doing okay and,
and immediately I'm like,
all right,
he is going to be this loud,
the whole game.
I am going into the other room.
So this is where it gets bad.
Now I'm in the other room.
You want to be that fucking loud,
be that fucking lab.
But now when he starts doing is anytime the ravens make a great play,
he comes in.
Oh,
I notice,
you know,
like when Kevin Garnett fucking dunks the ball and you just see him screaming.
That's what he was doing.
Anytime the ravens were doing anything,
he was doing that.
Like he was doing it.
So what we started doing,
because he was fat,
we started yelling out appetizers.
Like
you'd be like,
Rah ray bands.
We like potato skins,
fucking buffalo wing.
It's gray.
And it just,
it started off funny and then by the end it just started getting really ugly and
it almost was like escalating into a,
I dunno dude,
he's just,
it was just one of those classic situations where,
um,
you know what I kept thinking of,
I just was wishing Joe pass,
she was there,
you know what casino or he stabs the person in the neck with the pen and then a
down in the ground.
Like he goes,
who's that?
Is that a little girl?
How are you a little here.
A little girl crying down there like the lily.
That's what I wanted to do by the end of it.
And um,
I don't know man like that.
That's why I don't like going to sports bars cause I literally look at,
I love talking Shit and you know,
you show up and your team gets your ass,
gets her ass kick you,
you got to take the shit.
But like it gets to a certain point where now you're like yelling at me or in my
direction,
like I'm going to be intimidated by you and now you're making me feel like I'm
some sort of bitch and now I gotta Yell Shit Back at you.
And it just like,
I kind of left it with like a headache and it like,
it wasn't
I and I gotta admit like,
I even hate like the,
there's a,
there's a particular person down at that bar who's a patriots fan who's,
it's just a fucking asshole.
Um,
I was just wondering,
you guys have any stories like that?
Like you go to the sports bar,
the guy who like takes it too far.
Have you ever seen it actually escalate into a fight?
Because I always want to see those guys get punched in the face.
And a,
I'm not going to do it because a,
I don't want to get my ass kicked and be,
I don't want to,
you know,
you know the option a,
you get your ass kicked,
which is of me on the ground.
You know,
when you get your ass kicked out,
you how messed up your hair gets
you breathing really hard and you're trying not to cry.
Ah,
it just always feels like the playground.
It was mine was up.
Just be like grass in your hair.
Remember that Shit when you got your ass kicked in the playground,
how just alive you were at afterwards where you could just fucking feel
everything in your ears were always hot.
You know,
it's just fucking weird.
Anyways,
um,
the fuck am I talking about?
Yeah.
That's just sort of the option now in public where it's like,
if,
uh,
that's,
that's the situation now when you get into a fight,
either you fight new,
lose or you win and you get sued.
Dude,
I'm really sorry about my throat this week around.
What the fuck's going on here?
Like,
did you guys see a,
did I talk about,
I am so fucking out of the Jersey shore.
Was that last two weeks ago?
Up this past week.
This fucking guy starts talking to one of the castmates.
Alright.
And he at,
at a bar and he's trying to cause a fight.
He's just begging for a fight and the kid keeps tone.
Do you know,
I don't want to talk to you,
leave,
go away.
And it finally escalates into a fight and the kid from the Jersey shore fucking
kit gets onto a couple of knees,
you know the classic bar fight and ends up on the ground and the other guy's
getting noogies to the back of their head.
Right?
You guys,
I want noogies ours at an east coast thing.
Those are those short little quick punches that are just pretty much a knuckle
based.
It's like the Bruce Lee one inch punch without the power.
He's just sort of wrapping on your head like it's a door.
Um,
and now I evidently that kid's getting sued.
It's like for what?
Cause he won the fight.
The other kid wanted to fight.
I Dunno.
I think it's fucking stupid.
And then of course his girlfriend was really the one provoking it because the
guy was ignoring them in the girlfriend kept talking shit.
Of course she does.
Of course she talks shit because she doesn't have to fight him.
It was hilarious.
So then when they go to square off,
the other guy's girlfriend actually starts walking up to the Jersey shore kit
and it's just trying to just standing there scratching his face.
And what's funny,
she's doing it with one hand and there are other hand is just hanging down at
her side.
She doesn't have it up blocking that side of her head.
She doesn't need to cause he,
she knows she's not,
he's not going to hit her.
So the other girl causes the fight,
escalates into a fight and then the other girl gets to walk up and just sort of
take swipes at this kid's face.
Then the two guys fight the fight ends,
the Jersey shore kid gets up and then the girl or the other,
the,
the fucking Jersey shore girls going,
oh my God,
Oh my God,
the kids go and get the fuck away from me.
You caused that.
And um,
at one point I got to back up here at one point during the fight he was going,
he's going,
honey,
stop it.
Stop.
Just stop talking to the guy.
And she wouldn't.
So he pushed her not hard,
just pushing away.
You kind of go over a step and a half and I swear to God,
she goes back to the house and who ends up feeling like the,
like the victim.
She does.
And she starts crying and I was sitting at to my girlfriend,
you watch,
she caused this fight.
This guy just rolled around on the ground with this guy and for all,
you know,
he did.
The guy's like a black belt in Jujitsu and he's going to fucking rip his ear off
or stab them.
Oh God knows what he's rolling around on this,
you know,
he actually gets punched in the fucking face and now I sweat the girls crying
about it.
The girl who caused it as crying.
And I said to my girl,
I said,
you watch,
he's going to end up apologizing.
And of course he does.
And she said,
they're going,
you traumatize me.
Would you pushed me?
Ugh,
fucking I,
I just,
you know,
I don't understand it.
I guess I'll give the guy a pass because he's young.
I was just,
you know,
I was just waiting.
I traumatize you.
Really.
You just caused the fucking fight.
And not only that is I'm fighting a guy,
the other girl's chick is coming in fucking hit me in the head and you did
nothing.
You know what?
I lost interest in that story halfway through it.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's plow through here.
What the fuck can we wrap this podcast up with?
This is actually a really short one.
Um,
and I always say I'm going to wrap this up and then I never fucking do.
all right.
Why don't we end with this segment?
I'm sure I can do another 10 minutes on this to give you at least 45 minutes for
the week.
Let's end with this.
This segment.
Oh Jesus.
Which is really taking on a life of its own.
I thought it was going to die,
but it is somehow risen.
Um,
okay.
Here we go.
And get ready for bill is the dumbest person on the planet.
All right,
Bill,
for what it's worth,
I think you're fucking crazy and irresponsible explanation point.
I can never say the x,
x skull.
Exclaim exclamation.
There we go.
Exclamation point.
That's one of the,
you know,
those words that you kind of know how to say,
but you just sort of fly through them.
Escalation point.
Uh,
what kind of person talks about God like that?
And I love this shit.
This is what they all do.
You should.
And I believe deep down inside you are,
be ashamed of yourself.
Dude.
This is what I love about these fucking maniacs is they are so wrapped up into
what they believe that they listen to,
how much this person just keeps fucking including other invisible people.
And then super imposing what he believes into what you know.
He thinks.
I truly believe,
because he's so wrapped up in his own fucking world that he can't possibly even
fathom that somebody has a difference of opinion on this subject.
So he goes,
uh,
you should,
and I believe deep down inside you are,
be ashamed of yourself.
Dude.
Are Your mom and dad's still alive?
What exactly does that have to do with any,
your shtick with respect to God is hurtful,
offensive,
and despicable.
Um,
three things that always has to be three things.
It can't be hurtful.
And despicable or offensive and hurtful.
It has to be hurtful,
offensive and despicable.
Just like comedy has to come in threes.
Um,
how difficult it must be to spew hatred and vulgarities for shock value.
Laughs,
no talent in that my friend.
That's the classic place that people go.
Um,
whenever you,
this is the classic guy where everything is funny until it comes around to the
subject that they take seriously 100% and no one can even joke it,
joke about it or even questioned it on any level.
And then they always say that you're just doing it for shock because they find
it shocking.
It's like really my views on women,
women haven't been,
you know,
that didn't offend you.
All this shit that I've said over the two fucking years.
None of that is offended you and Al of a sudden this does anyway,
so he goes,
enjoy your success,
air quotes and all the money you were making on the backs of hardworking,
decent people that understand what it means to follow the rules and be the best
they can be without putting other people and god down.
The rest of us are watching and we are not laughing.
Dude.
How many people are in your bedroom as your,
do you ever group podcast listening party every week?
All right,
let's get back that.
Oh,
evidently I am making a money on the backs of hardworking,
decent people.
So let me get this straight because I'm standing on a stage.
Evidently what I'm doing is not hard work and if people are sitting in the
audience automatically,
they're all decent,
hardworking people.
And not only that,
I'm making money on the backs of them,
really do I have some sort of comedy sweatshop like,
you know,
comedy factory was sweatshop Labor.
What I do is actually takes advantage of no one.
I stand on a stage and I,
I tell jokes and if you like what I say,
you,
you sit and listen.
And if you don't,
you walk out
right where,
where,
you know,
and I love how just because you're in the crowd,
that means you're a decent human being.
Do you know the amount of fucking freaks and scumbags that come up to me?
This is what I found at a comedy show for the most part.
Decent people.
They leave after the show that I didn't want to bug him and then they walk out
and then mania come up to me.
You know,
let's do some Yeager and they fucking spitting in your face and shit.
believe me.
All right?
But I know I made fun of God.
So now,
uh,
you know on,
now all of a sudden I'm now all of a sudden you want to talk about people
making,
making money off of decent,
hardworking people.
Take a look at fucking organized religion.
All right,
those guys,
those guys are live in pretty good.
Scaring the fucking shit out of you.
Every God damn week.
All right.
And I'm entitled to an opinion and I never was cramming my opinion down your
throat.
I wasn't okay.
You believe in what you believe in,
and I 100% respect that,
but I have the right to question it.
You know,
and you shouldn't find it shocking that I questioned it.
You should do and shouldn't you just be what Jesus would do when Jesus just
start praying for me.
Anyways,
let's,
let's continue this just in case you're interested.
I was raised Catholic,
married and raised my children Catholic and definitely have my doubts about the
whole organized religion thing.
Great.
So you agree with me?
Not even sure that I believe in God.
Once again,
there's another that we,
that we agree on.
I lost my father three years ago and never would have uttered these words in his
presence.
Neither would I.
What am I voice?
Go Up.
So you know what dude,
I did it on a podcast.
All right,
I'm sorry your father passed away.
But you know,
that has nothing to do with me.
Do you understand what you're doing here?
Now all of a sudden you're making it seem like I'm walking in with my Mr
microphone into the intensive care saying there's no god,
you know,
whispering into somebodies ear in a coma.
You just go into the ground.
We're all like,
dear,
I'm not doing that.
I'm doing a podcast and I'm fucking around.
Alright,
if you want to take it seriously,
that's your problem.
Okay.
And if you want to bring up your father,
passing away is some way to try to guilt me in to feeling like,
I mean,
you know what I'm saying?
In a hateful,
hurtful,
fucking way.
Dude,
those are all your issues.
They have nothing to do with me.
All right?
Then he goes on to say that his dad believed that there is something out there
responsible for all the beauty in the world,
uh,
in our world and for our lives as human beings.
I don't even disagree with that.
I just know human beings have no idea what it is until they fucking die.
So I'm not going to sit there and listen to another human being who tries to
scare the shit out of me.
And who was living in a fucking palace telling me that if I become rich,
I'm not going to heaven.
I'm not out of my mind to think that that reeks of a fucking scam.
The same way late at night when they have those fucking gold coins that
evidently are with 50 bucks and they're selling them for 1999 that that doesn't
reek of a scam.
Somebody actually sent me a a,
an email.
Of course,
I didn't save it.
Evidently it's sprayed with like a dollar,
something worth a gold.
Okay,
so they're making,
what is that?
A 2000% profit.
All right.
Believe it or not,
just because you're walking around talking about religion and the afterlife and
and doing unto others,
and you're talking this great game,
it doesn't mean that you can't be full of shit.
All right?
Okay.
And I'm not saying that I'm right about what I feel,
but this is just,
it reeks of,
of,
of a scam.
I really believe that there is some sort of thing out there and I wouldn't be
surprised if there is something after this.
I wouldn't be surprised if you just go into the ground and you decay and you
give life to the next fucking thing.
I wouldn't be surprised if earth is punishment for something that I did in an a
different solar system.
That's another thing about religion and forget about the dinosaurs is it doesn't
even bring up space.
Okay.
Let's say there is this all powerful being okay.
And I'm just trying to question this right now.
So I'm not trying to be shocking or I'm just questioning this.
Let's say there is this all powerful being,
being there,
created the everything that there is.
Okay.
The entire solar system.
Why would you do all of that and just put people on this one planet that's like
you created an in uh,
he built this house that has in an infinity basically amount of rooms,
bedrooms and you just put everybody,
you're only using one room in the house.
It doesn't make any fucking sense whatsoever.
And that's one thing about Scientology for as much shit as people give
Scientology,
at least it has the brains to incorporate out or space,
you know?
I don't know if that's a really good point,
if that's really fucking stupid,
but you know,
I don't fucking know.
So anyways,
yeah,
dude,
I wasn't trying to offend you or anything that you fucking,
I was just trying to be funny and I'm just fucking around and if you want to
take this shit seriously,
that,
that is totally your fucking choice.
Um,
you know,
that's it.
All right.
I'm fucking done with that.
All right,
let's move on to the next trashing me.
Um,
oh,
what the fuck?
Where the fuck is it?
Jesus Christ.
I think I only,
I only put one of my thought.
I had another one.
I'm really just organized this week.
That's because you don't have changes in your life.
You don't have Jason,
another guy said,
I love how you pick on a,
on a,
uh,
a punching bag of religion,
basically saying like,
it's very easy to make fun of Christians,
but I don't dare make fun of Muslims because if you make fun of them,
Oh Shit,
look what's going to happen,
you know?
And,
which I thought was fucking hilarious because the person was sitting there
talking about how insensitive I am.
And that basically,
in a roundabout way,
we're alluding to the fact that people who are Muslim means that you're a,
you're a fucking,
uh,
you know,
you're going to blow up.
Like they're all gonna blow up planes and that type of shit.
You know,
I went to a wedding one time,
this girl was Pakistani and they actually addressed that.
That's what they fucking hated was that all,
you know,
Christians thought that all of them just wanted to walk around blowing up shit.
And uh,
and I also,
it was funny that this guy's fucking sitting there suggesting that,
uh,
people just because they're Christian,
that they're peaceful way.
And you know,
what does it,
once every 18 months,
some Jesus freaks fucking kills an abortion doctor.
That's pretty much par for the course,
isn't it?
Um,
no,
and it's,
it,
it's not safe to make fun of Jesus freaks.
It really isn't.
It really fucking isn't.
I think Bill Maher is out of his fucking mind to say what he says and like are
actually has balls the size of the Grand Canyon to say what the fuck he says and
then just walk out and wade into those people and just a,
I would never do that shit anyways and I got to admit the level of which that
people take this shit seriously.
It actually kind of creeps me out to,
to continue talking about this shit.
So,
uh,
this might be the last fucking week of it because I've definitely made my
fucking points and at this point we're just going to go around in circles and
I'm just going to piss people off.
So,
uh,
let's move on to this last guy who actually brought up some great points.
Um,
all right,
set a bunch of Nice stuff and then he said,
enough with the Dick Sucking.
I was gonna I was going to criticize religion,
but to describe those belief is,
is to mock them.
Beth.
And you know what dude?
That's what I learned.
Um,
yeah,
if you could describe them,
then you start making fun of them and then everybody gets mad.
Or as you're saying,
they're just so ridiculous.
You just have to,
you know.
Anyways,
let's fly ahead here.
Yeah.
You said,
you mentioned needing a code in the absence of religion to live by.
Um,
I'm not sure how much,
um,
of the,
I don't read things as a Shtick,
but I recommend an excellent text used in an intro to Undergrad and Undergrad
ethics course called the elements of moral philosophy by James.
I don't know if that's rock hills or Rachael's,
um,
everybody goes on and on about cheeses,
but Socrates who define morality is how we ought to live.
Let a compelling life,
as you probably know.
Actually,
I don't,
I just know him as a party reference.
Um,
what do you fucking Socrates,
you know,
that's one of those references that even morons can use and get away with.
And I'm sad to say I'm one of those people.
Um,
he said,
I didn't know this shit.
He was found guilty of corrupting the youth.
He thought Zeus,
Venus,
Aries,
etc.
Smacked of bullshit.
All right.
Think about that.
Right?
They're corrupting the youth now.
Every why Christians,
Muslims and everybody today would say that.
Yeah,
that is bullshit.
That those people do not exist because now we've evolved to,
there's only one God.
There's only one bank.
There's one world power.
Um,
and let's see.
And as punishment,
he was forced to take his own life by drinking hemlock poison.
Once again another death because of organized religion.
You know,
these Jesus freaks,
these,
these people who are into fucking,
I didn't,
we don't want the reason why I don't make fun of,
uh,
the Muslim religion is really because I don't know anything about it.
And the reason why I make fun of Christianity's because that's what I was
brought up.
And those are the stories that,
that I,
that I hear and all I know about Muslims is basically,
uh,
you know,
the couple of wars with Iraq.
So I basically don't know shit.
I just think what you wrap your,
wrap your women up in bounty paper towels and then cut their clips off in,
am I wrong?
Am I wrong on that one?
Either.
They're not allowed to show their fucking thongs because,
uh,
you're going to get an erection.
And because you were that bed sheet,
everybody's going to fucking see it.
I don't,
I don't really think about it,
but I would definitely make fun of it if I knew something about it,
but I don't.
All right.
And I reserve the right to make fun of the fucker religion that I was brought
up.
And,
um,
so anyways,
he says I'm,
Socrates was a humble man,
famously announcing all I know is my ignorance.
Um,
he sought the one that I love,
people who would take that at face value.
See,
he said he was you fucking moron right there,
right there.
You know,
Jesus is the solution.
Um,
he sought answers to questions.
Where is religions prohibits questioning answers a fucking brilliant,
this guy is really smart.
You should do a podcast instead of me.
I'm a fucking idiot.
Listen to,
he sought answers to questions,
whereas religion prohibits questioning answers and if anything fucking proves
that it's the 50 emails I got this week.
Ah,
I like how I'm actually asking like I'm questioning religion on any sort of
intelligent level.
Um,
I think actually I think I am just because I say cut and fuck doesn't mean I'm
not,
uh,
bringing up some good questions.
All right.
Let's finish this for,
uh,
for Socrates.
The unexamined life is not worth living.
Um,
his sentiments on marriage and nagging women are remarkably Marmar,
probably similar to your own,
so underrated Socrates,
overrated.
Jesus.
Uh,
yeah,
I,
that's,
you know,
that's dead.
That is the one thing,
and I'm not being a dick here that I don't understand about people who,
like I respect
people who,
who,
you know,
are raised in religion or,
or find a religion that speaks to them and then they decide to commit their
lives to what,
and what I don't understand is,
you know,
and it brings you this piece,
right?
Am I wrong there?
All right.
So it brings you this piece.
But then if anybody questions
that belief that you have,
how quickly it turns violent,
like the amount of people who die because they question these a holy people is
this.
You don't find that fucking like hilarious and ridiculous on any level
like this sitting there calling the other person the devil,
because they're questioning their beliefs and they're saying that that other
person is going to hell.
And then they turn around and kill the person because they don't believe in the
holy pure way that they lived their life.
I mean,
I just,
I can't get behind that.
I can't get behind that the same way.
Is that the same way?
It's just because you're a red sox fan.
You can't recognize the talent of Derek Jeter.
And I gotta be like,
do full cubies you fig.
Now he's the shit.
I don't fucking know why.
Why do I continue with this shit?
Um,
anyways,
so that's the podcast for the week.
Uh,
this person actually goes on to recommend a movie.
Um,
he says,
I heard you mentioned the departed a few times.
Um,
if you haven't already,
you might want to check out state of grace and overlook mobster flipped from
1990 that was unfortunately released around the same time as good fellers
Goodfellas and a Miller's crossing it as Sean Penn,
Ed Harris,
Burgess,
Meredith,
Robin white topless.
All right.
That made it a little creepy.
And Gary Oldman,
who gives an Oscar caliber performance.
All right.
Yeah,
if you guys haven't seen state of grace,
I've seen that.
Uh,
I'm actually due to watch that again.
Um,
Gary Oldman is,
you know what,
if you just saw him play commissioner Gordon in Batman and the reserve
performance that he did and then you see them in state of grace,
you'll realize why that guy is.
Even though people recognize him as an incredible actor,
he still,
I think one of the most underrated actors of all time.
He's fucking unbelievable.
And you have to see the face Ed Harris makes,
um,
without ruining the movie.
He gets betrayed and when he realizes that he's portrayed the fucking,
the way he twists up his face at Harris is another one.
Dude that movie is like,
um,
the guys that are in that movie for me are the modern day.
Like,
uh,
I didn't,
and this is a big statement because you can never replace those guys,
but it was my generation's
Bronson,
Lee Marvin,
you know,
just the Guy Guy,
the guys guys like you just wanted to be those guys and they always had guns and
they never took any shit.
It's just,
it's just fuck,
you know,
Gary Oldman,
uh,
and uh,
um,
ed Harris.
Yeah.
Who else do I put in that?
Okay.
It's a very short fucking list.
It's very hard the way.
Um,
okay.
Nowadays in movies I think to be the guy,
you know,
that,
that classic,
you know,
women want to get with them and guys want to be him.
And I think a lot of it is because,
yeah,
back in the day,
like those being in shape,
you just,
you were just in sort of regular shape and then it was the way you carried
yourself kind of like what's his face and Ben Kingsley and sexy piece.
Do you guys ever seen that movie?
I know I brought it up a bunch of times,
but I remember he was in an inside the actor's studio one time and they asked
him if he worked out before he played a four.
He played that character and um,
he said no,
it was all the way I held my body.
He just stood more like erect and he had like perfect posture and he just looked
like this tough as nails guy even though it was Ben Kingsley.
And I think there was something about those older guys like Steve Mcqueen and
those guys that just the way they held themselves because you look at them,
they all like Yule Brenner.
I mean all those guys,
they were like 140 pounds,
but somehow you just look at him like,
dude,
I wouldn't fuck with those guys.
And then like all the star to many of the stars nowadays,
they got like highlights in their hair and they got abs and they got 'em all
oiled up and shit.
You're looking at black guys effect,
you know,
I dunno.
Did Stars back in the day?
Did they,
did they fucking shave their chest hair and landscaped their eyebrows?
I think there's just something about it,
man.
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
And once again,
I'm not disrespecting your religions.
Okay?
But this is my podcast.
And when I bring shit up,
I fucking go off on it.
And I,
and I definitely go over the top saying that somebody was playing the upright
bass with Jesus's Juggler is fucking hilarious because it's over the top.
And I believe the God in my world thinks it's funny.
He's God.
Why would he be intimidated?
I,
that's another thing too.
I don't understand why God would make all this stuff.
Okay.
And then just be so doe angry all the time.
Jesus Christ here.
I'd gone back in and again,
I've got a lot of questions.
Fuck you.
It's my podcast.
I,
that's why I don't understand.
You know,
I is,
it was more like,
you know,
when you,
when you build a bookshelf and you just stand back a Meijer in your work and
then it falls down on the floor and you're like God damn fucking piece of Shit
and you start blaming the bookshelf even though you made it,
you're the one who put it up there.
You know,
I guess technically God didn't make a,
he didn't make titty bars.
I guess those are manmade,
but uh,
you know the broad cinema ma or are,
wow.
I'm really fucking,
I was just gonna say maintenance image isn't that,
isn't that what you guys say?
They found a devil.
That's the devil.
They got the devil in them.
Um,
all right.
What have,
all I'm saying is because it really got serious,
this sweet people,
people really got fucking,
they took it a little too seriously.
All right,
so back the fuck off.
Stop taking it so God damn seriously.
And you know,
why don't you actually practice what your preacher preaches and why don't you go
pray for me?
Why don't you do that?
Instead of coming on here telling me,
you know,
giving me your wrath.
Isn't that one of the seven deadly sins?
You fucking maniacs.
You just as fucked up as I am and you don't know shit either.
All right?
All right.
I'm sorry.
God bless all of you.
Okay.
I hope you find what works for you and a seriously,
if I'm bugging you,
don't listen to the podcast.
God knows I'm not making any money off it.
I don't give a fuck.
And that's it.
You guys all have a great weekend.
A,
I tell you where I was going to be this week,
but I'm worried some Jesus freak is going to show up.
So,
uh,
that's it.
That's it.
Have a great week and I'll talk to you next month.
Hopefully.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].